Any mutation that results in changing the overall
reading frame is called a frame shift mutation.
It just means a mutation that alters the
reading frame of translation which is exactly what happened
here. Cytosine got inserted, and then everything got
pushed down a notch. And it's not just that
it got pushed down, all the later codons
changed because of this shift. Often times frameshift mutations
result in premature stop codons which is exactly
what happened here. And this is exactly what
happens in Crohn's Disease. This particular mutation is
associated with Crohn's disease because the NOD2 gene,
when a C gets inserted, The reading frame
gets shifted. A premature stop codon shows up,
a nonsense mutation now and the overall protein
is shortened or truncated. Losing it's original function
thus causing this particular disorder. Take
this particular sequence here. I've even numbered
the positions for you for all 15 letters in the sequence. I want you
tell me which of the following five options would result in a frameshift to
the sequence. Go ahead and check any and all boxes that you think apply.